it's important for your app to stay up
to date in order to give the latest
Social Feeds news and weather reports to
your users but in truth syncing too
often can be the worst idea for the
performance of your application my name
is Colt McAnlis and there's one hard and
fast rule when it comes to syncing your
data over the network
do not over sync I mean it's a pretty
common situation now the user has your
app active or maybe it was the last app
they used and you want to make sure that
there's plenty of new data available for
them so that they won't close your app
or let their attention wander elsewhere
so you sink you sink a lot you ping the
server you ask for new data and bring it
down as often as you can but let's face
it this is a horrible idea firstly this
destroys the users battery and as we've
said before networking is the single
biggest battery hog there is not only
does it drain battery just to initialize
the chip but then it keeps it awake for
an additional 20 to 60 seconds after
you're done with your request also
drawing power in fact you can fall into
a really bad place where each one of
your networking requests ends up waking
up the radio and paying this cost not
ideal secondly consider the sheer volume
of bits that your app is now responsible
for requesting on the user's phone for
users on restricted usage data plans
this can be a make-or-break crime I mean
one app eating up a months worth of
bandwidth simply because it keeps
pinging the server for new data not a
good idea and this is also a double
whammy because the slower the connection
the longer the radio stays on to help
transfer data meaning that you're not
only being taxed for bits on the wire
but also draining more battery as a
result so okay so syncing too often is
bad but let's be realistic here your app
needs the data in order to provide the
user with the best experience we can't
just cut syncing out completely right
and the truth is you don't have to
there's a few handy tricks that you can
employ which will give the user the same
sense of functionality but require much
fewer requests the key to this solution
is understanding the difference between
stuff that has to happen right now and
stuff that can be delayed for example if
the user takes an action requesting that
their news feed updates right now well
then you pretty much have to kick off
that request but really the second and
third types are where you can actually
start improving performance the requests
that happen on regular intervals that
keep things up to date but don't need to
happen right this second
it's not super important right now then
you can be smarter about how it's synced
case in point you should really never
pull the server regularly for updates
you're basically just wasting bandwidth
and battery for the server to tell you
that nothing's changed instead it's
better to leverage other services like
Google Cloud messaging which what the
server signal the app when there's new
content this will reduce the amount of
battery turn the phone is doing and
reduce the overall number of server
responses that you need to worry about
now if there's a situation where you
simply have to sync then make sure that
you're not doing it on regular intervals
remember this wastes resources and most
of the time there won't be new content
waiting for you instead adopt a back off
pattern based on responses for instance
if no new data is available double the
length you wait until you check again if
nothing's available the next time double
your weight length again this will still
allow you to sync against the data but
will slowly back away from higher
activity based on how frequent the
server-side information is updating and
don't forget you can also adjust seek
frequency based on user activity for
example if you can detect that the user
is driving or running or if the phone
has entered into the sleep mode you can
make a good assumption that they won't
need data at the same rate on the other
side though if you've noticed that the
phone has been asleep for eight hours
and suddenly starts getting moved around
then there's a good chance the user has
just woken up and it might be the right
time to kick off a sync request and
finally don't hesitate to adjust your
sync frequency based on the state of the
device waiting for it to be plugged in
or connected to Wi-Fi to do syncing
helps keep the battery happy while users
are out and about and the good news is
that you can update your app to adopt
these patterns without having to write a
massive amount of code GCM network
manager is a Google Play services API
which helps the scheduled network
oriented tasks and handle batching for
you this greatly simplifies the
implementation of common patterns such
as waiting for network connectivity
Network retries and exponential back-off
basically all the good stuff you need
with one single helpful API and if
you're ever wondering how your
application is using the network make
sure to check out the network traffic
tool inside of Android studio it will
easily show you the frequency of your
data transfers and the amount of data
transferred during each connection of
course that's what it all comes down to
right watch some videos and prove your
app make your users happier but you
or not done yet that's why you need to
check out the rest of the Android
performance patterns content and don't
forget to join the Google+ community as
well so keep calm profile your code and
always remember perf matters